die ifa 2020 sie tatsächlich ganz anders
aus denn sie ist nur für fachbesucher
geöffnet aber deswegen haben wir hier
einen riesengroßen stand aufgebaut und
werden dreimal täglich von genau hier
senden damit sie auch kein highlight
hier verfassen und dazu habe ich
verstärkung dazu gehörte martin
eisenlauer bild tk experte hallo martin
ja was erwartet uns denn dieses jahr auf
der ifa 2020 unter diesen umständen ja
die ifa ist ganz anders aber die
produkte sind eigentlich die die wir
sonst auch kennen nämlich das was wir
uns am ende dann zu weihnachten wünschen
nämlich neue fernseher neue levels neue
smarte geräte für unser zuhause und
geräte die dinge einfacher machen
eines der highlights der messe kommt von
samsung und das hat sich unser kollege
sven stein schon mal angeguckt das
können wir jetzt auch mal anschauen
das machen wir ein faltbares händen
nicht anfang august hatte samsung ist
schon mal kurz angeteasert und offiziell
den namen verraten jetzt bekommt es
seine eigene große bühne
das samsung galaxy s at 25 g
das dritte handy von samsung mit einem
faltbaren bildschirm was ist neu bei dem
modell auf der vorderseite ist jetzt ein
großes 6,2 zoll display eingebaut dass
sich quasi über die gesamte frontseite
zieht das heiler ist aber natürlich im
inneren der faltbare bildschirm der
jetzt 7,6 zoll misst was fällt noch auf
hier oben dies elfi kamera ist in diesem
bildschirm verbaut werden sie beim
vorgängermodell noch in so einer
größeren aussparungen untergebracht war
das material des bildschirms ist nicht
bei wie beim vorgänger kunststoff
sondern hier ein samsung ein biegsames
glas verbaut letztlich eine mischung aus
glas und kunststoff und wie fühlt sich
wenn man mit dem finger darüber wischt
nicht ganz so stumpf an wie beim wie
beim ersten fall handy sondern hier
gleitet der finger sanft über diese
oberfläche
auf der rückseite hat samsung dem 1 2
eine kamera mit drei objektiven
spendiert die fotografieren mit 12
megapixel auflösung und dies elfi kamera
macht bilder mit 10 megapixeln insgesamt
macht das gerät beim ersten ausprobieren
einen sehr edlen eindruck
der rahmen ist sehr schön gearbeitet ist
auch sehr schmal rund um das display das
gerät wird zu einem preis von 2000 euro
auf den markt kommen das heißt es wird
ebenso viel kosten wie das
vorgängermodell folgt das im vergangenen
jahr auf den markt kam und nicht damit
etwas über dem zett flip das für 1500
euro weiter zu kaufen lassen
ja das also ein highlight mehr als gibt
es dann morgen ab 10 uhr von der ifa
live auch mit martin dabei wir werden
ihnen die highlights vorstellen und
damit zurück zu dir liebe teresa di
siena und genau da hast du schon gesagt
morgen um 10 um 13 uhr und um 16 uhr